life in one of the world's largest oil
producing Nations Venezuelans say
shouldn't be this difficult
and access to a basic human right should
be easier
they charge us two or two and a half
dollars for water it's too much we can't
do it anymore because nobody can put up
with that sometimes the guys here bring
us water from the well and sell it
cheaper for more than 20 years we
haven't known what it's like to have tap
water
running water has long been a luxury and
the sprawling low-income neighborhoods
around Caracas
state-owned company is in charge of
supplying water practically free of
charge but it is unable to keep up with
Rising demand
some residents of pitare Venezuela's
largest favela benefit from a nearby
well where they can collect groundwater
others siphon tap water from broken
pipes
we come here to get drinking water every
two weeks for use at the house I have to
fetch and carry every day because we
only have running water sometimes once a
week and for two hours or an hour and a
half of that otherwise we don't have
water
shrinking wages and Rising prices make
access to water more difficult even
informal Traders are increasing prices
for jugs and tanker water but these
sources are still preferable because
they are more reliable than the state
for access to the most essential
resource for life
Zane basavi Al Jazeera
let's get more on this we're joined Now
by Richard Connor he's the
editor-in-chief of the United Nations
World water development report and he's
joining us from the UN in New York very
good to have you with us on Al Jazeera
we've been going over the numbers of
people who don't have constant access to
Safe water and sanitation and they're
absolutely alarming is the world going
to achieve the sustainable development
goal of water and sanitation for all by
uh one would hope so but if we if we
manage to do it it's because we will
have but a lot more effort than than we
have been putting so far towards uh
water and sanitation uh I've been
listening to uh attentively to the the
last stories we've got Venezuela
Colombia and Bangladesh and these are
places where it's not a question of
water truly physical water scarcity what
we're talking about there is economic
water scarcity the water is there the
resources are there but they're not
getting to the people that really need
it and uh certainly not in an affordable
way so that's the number one place in
terms of making a difference in people's
lives where we really have to focus our
attention
and so as well as focusing the attention
there's also been talk that you know
countries have to quadruple their
efforts to be able to ensure
safe water and sanitation for all what
else needs to happen to achieve that
goal
foreign
the efforts in and of itself is is a
very tall order uh it's a question it's
a it's a lot of we talk about investment
and indeed uh the investment in water
and sanitation has to increase but it's
not just in terms of investing in pipes
and treatment plants and and so in
infrastructure what's really missing is
capacity so that you know the
municipalities themselves uh have the
expertise not only to build but to
actually operate uh these systems and
provide the level of services that
people require to meet even the most
basic needs which are uh and achieve the
human rights to water and sanitation and
what you're mentioning it sounds like
you know those things are more
applicable to lower income countries
whereas the risks related to water
quality I mean there's just as many
risks I was quite surprised to read with
in relation to water quality in
low-income countries as there are in
higher income countries too
no that's true
um in in low-income countries the the
number one cause of water pollution is
untreated Wastewater uh 80 of the
world's Wastewater is released to the
environment without any treatment at all
and in a lot of developing countries
it's it's 99 it's pretty much everything
but in developed countries the water
pollution is caused by agricultural
runoff so these are inefficient
irrigation systems that use more water
than they should and
um the agricultural runoff is filled
with nitrogen basically nutrients or
fertilizers herbicides pesticides and so
uh even in developed countries there's a
lot of efforts that need to be done to
reduce pollution and thus protect the
resource yeah I mean some of the issues
that you just mentioned about higher
income countries I know they're very
applicable to you know where I'm from
New Zealand where people have no idea
that runoff agricultural runoff is a
huge problem in regards to water
pollution and we've been covering this
conference that's taking place on water
at the United Nations in New York where
you are the first of its kind in 45
years how hopeful are you that it will
be able to produce something concrete
given that you know there's no binding
agreements expected and the commitments
will be voluntary
well it's a matter of opinion uh of
course yeah some internationally binding
agreement would be fine but how really
useful would it be it's really up to up
to different countries member states to
make sure that they that the populations
do receive the services that they
deserve at an affordable price and that
the resource is well managed and
protected as well uh and so it's not
really International laws or agreements
that are going to protect uh the
ecosystems and the you know the basins
and the rivers right that's really at
the national level so hopefully you know
this the momentum created by this
meeting or this conference will actually
push member states to you know a lot of
them might have environmental protective
protection laws but they're not
necessarily enforcing them so uh so the
idea is to give to put pressure on the
member states to adopt these laws but
also enforce them and make sure that uh
that water is well managed and protected
all right that is Richard Connor the
editor-in-chief of the United Nations
World water development report thank you
so much for your time we do appreciate
it
thank you Elizabeth